تنوع المثير للدهشه في الجزيره العربيه
والانفتاح ايضا وبنفس الوقت الحفاظ
والاعتزاز بالهويه لماذا البعض يضيق ذرعا
بذلك رغم ان حتى غير حديث العلم انا مثلا
همم
وجدت في وثائق الرؤيا رؤيه 2030 تحت عنوان
الثقافه والناس هذا الناس تمتاز الحياه
السعوديه بالتنوع الاجتماعي الذي يشكل
ثراء همم ساهم
ثقافيه ساهم في رسم هويه غنيه لسكان
المملكه ثم اخر تنفرد مناطق السعوديه اللي
هي 13 منطقه بلا هجاتها وعاداتها
وتقاليدها ومطبخها الى اخرها
هو هذا التنوع هو مصدر قوه وليس مصدر ضعيف
همم اللي كتب هذا الكلام يعي تماما بانه
بانه يتكلم عن التاريخ القديم التاريخ
القديم في الجزيره العربيه في تنوع ثقافه
في تنوع حضاري تنوع لغه وتنوع في الاجابات
هو نفس ما تعيش والمملكه العربيه
اليوم التي تغطي اكثر من اثنين مليون كم
مربع لذلك الحقيقه همم
هذا اللي كتب هذا الكلام الحقيقه يعني فتح
لنا باب على ضروره الحقيقه الاهتمام بهذه
الثقافات وبهذا التراث الموجود عندنا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والاثار
الموجوده فيها وعندنا حقيقه مثال بسيط اذا
سمحت فيها اللي عندنا في مركز الملك فيصل
الان نقوم بمشروع الحقيقه اسمه المرويه
العربيه وهذه المرويه العربيه اساسا تنطلق
الحقيقه لاعطاء الشعوب او القبائل العرب
خلينا نقول العرب في الجزيره العربيه
تحقهم الذي لا نريد ان نقول هضم لكن
بطريقه اكثر اكثر يعني ملامسه للواقع
واكثر انفتاح على الاخر لذلك هذا المشروع
الحقيقي اذا كتب له النجاح سوف يعطي
الحقيقه دفعه قويه جدا
يعني
مرويه العربيه يعني الروات شفويه العربيه
هو الحديث من خلال محاضرات خلال ورش عمل
من خلال كتب ومن خلال اقامه مشاريع ضخمه
من اجل تغطيه كل ما تضمنته الجزيره
العربيه من فنون الى انظمه سياسيه
واقتصاديه وديانات وغيرها كل هذه هتدخل
ضمن المرويه لذلك شامل الجزيره العربيه
كامله الجزيره العربيه العرب
العربيه العربيه فلذلك اعتقد انه من
الضروري بانه يعني طبعا نقدم شكري الحقيقه
لقائمين على مركز فيصل على تبني هذا الامر
لكن اتمنى واناشد يعني المسؤولين في وزاره
الثقافه وزاره السياحه في وزاره التربيه
والتعليم على همم او التعليم ان نسيت
اسمها التعريف بالراحه البيوت فيعني شو
اسمه ان همم تتكاثر جهودهم مع مع مركز
الملك فيصل ابراز هذا الدوري الحضاري
للعرب هو في الحقيقه في خاتمه هذا النقاش
اريد ان تقول باختصار دكتور من خلال
دراستك انت لهذه الحضارات العربيه القديمه
حتى الحضارات الاسلاميه همم الان الرؤيه
همم صراحه منحتنا نفسا جديدا وثقه جديده
لانه نصت على ان السعوديه همم يجب ان
تستغلك لونها ملتقى للحضارات حتى على
مستوى الجسر البري همم الرابط بين اسيا
وافريقيا مستوى الاستقطاب الكفاءات
والكفايات الخارجيه همم هذا الامر اعتقد
انه انه علماء الاثار لهم دور كبير يجب ان
يقوموا فيه فهل ترى انهم قاموا به في
تعزيز هذا التنوع الحضاري او ايصابه للناس
يعني
لكن همم لا شك انه يجب علينا احنا انا في
تصوري ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجزيره العربيه غنيه بالتراثها وغنيه
باثارها وغنيه بثقتها وفي وانا عندي
الحقيقه دائما اقول وزاره الثقافه لها دور
كبير جدا لان اؤمن وزاره الثقافي وزاره
السلوكيات وهي لا تقل اهميه عندي من وزاره
الدفاع ولوزاره الصحه ولا وزاره التعليم
بدون ان تكون هذه الوزاره الحقيقه تنتهي
ال ال ابراج السلوكيات الحقيقيه لمجتمع
للنجد بالناس الاخرين من ابرز الاشياء هو
الانفتاح الاخر احترام الاخر تقدير الاخر
والايمان باننا نحن في سفينه واحده لا يجب
الحقيقه ان ان ننظر للناس نظره غير طبيعيه
وفي نفس الوقت سلوكيات يجب ان تتحسن كما
كان سلوكيات اجدادنا الذين فتحوا بفكرهم
نير وبفكر من مفاتح قبل الاسلام بلدانا
وزاروا مالك فيها كل الممالك الساميه كانت
في قبائل العربيه هاجرت من الجزيره
العربيه لذلك وما هاجروا الفتره الاسلاميه
الا لانهم كانوا يتقبلون هذه الامور
ويندمجون مع المجتمع في حدود في حدود
معتقداتهم